>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Jack Gantos: Now I really
enjoyed researching this,
researching this author
and these books.
I just thought it was
so interesting,
as someone who I was
never much of a writer
but I probably should
have tried harder.
So now all of you kids who dream
of seeing your name on a book,
need to pay attention
for this author.
So this Newbery Award-winning
author, Jack Gantos,
inspires young writers to
utilize their writing radar,
which is a tool described in detail
of this book of the same name,
Writer Radar, using your journal
to snoop out and craft great ideas.
Jack is from Mount Pleasant,
Pennsylvania and has written books
for readers of all ages and has
continued to write children's books
and has begun to teach courses
in children's book writing
and children's literature.
See? Having so many talents can take
you wonderful places not unlike this
even today.
I'd say he is a jack-of-all-trades,
but that's a terrible joke.
But don't forget to stop by the
book signing area between 4:30
and 5:30 today to meet Jack and
have him sign a book for you.
And without further ado we
welcome to the stage Jack Gantos.
[ Applause ]
>> Okay. Was that the introduction?
That must have been
the introduction.
[ Applause ]
>> Okay. This is one of those
talks that's going to be
like launched out of a shotgun.
This is 25 minutes and we've
got a lot to cover when it comes
to children's literature; not
only the books themselves,
but the writing of the books.
So we've got literature and then
really what the purpose is today,
is to talk about how you can
write your own good books.
So you're going to walk out of here
with some tips, some good stuff
and I'd better get to it,
otherwise you're going to walk
out with half a mind of good stuff
and I want you to have a full mind.
Okay. Nobody can ever talk about
writing good books without talking
about reading good books, because
all writing starts with reading.
That is the first principle
of writing a good book,
being a good reader, right?
So for me, when I was
a kid-- I was a kid.
Let's see.
Move that forward.
Does it go that way?
The PowerPoint.
Hold on. Ah there we are.
Okay. There's the book.
Now boom. That's me.
First grade.
I went down to Mrs.
Niederheiser's class.
We didn't have kindergarten.
I was in the back yard
digging a hole.
Somebody came by slapped
me on the head and said,
hey, you should go to school.
I was like, okay.
So I walked down the hill
in western Pennsylvania,
probably carried a lump of
coal in my pocket and went down
and Mrs. Niederheiser
taught me how to read.
We played a lot of London
Bridges, that's what I recall.
But I did like books and I started
reading a lot of picture books.
And you all have read
a lot of picture books.
You remember Brown Bear, Brown Bear.
What do you see?
I see a red bug looking at me.
You remember the Hungry Caterpillar.
You remember George
and Martha Butcher.
You remember Loud Crocodile.
You remember all those
fabulous books.
Well they get into you.
So books got into me
and later on, boom.
What was I writing?
Picture books.
Why? Because I read
them and I loved them.
So the connection between what you
read and what you write is a lock.
Remember, choosing
the books you love
to read is also choosing the
future of what you want to write.
And then I got older.
Amazing I grew.
And I started writing these books.
Family books of short stories,
because I became a
diary writer as a kid.
And I used to go to the dining
room table with my diary,
keep it on my lap and when my
dad would tell a funny story,
I'd write it down.
When my sister would tell a
tragic story of her well--
10th grade life, I
would write it down.
And so I always liked
family stories.
And therefore-- oops we went back.
Now we're going forward one more.
There we are.
Joey Pigza.
Whoa, where'd that go?
Hold on. There's Joey.
So the Joey Pigza stories.
So when I was a kid, I was
a bit of an active kid.
I was like one of those
[inaudible]--
I wasn't off the charts
active, but I was pretty active.
And so later on, naturally
I wrote about who I was.
And then I got a little bit older.
That's my bicycle.
I used to ride around my
neighborhood with my diary
in that basket and spy on everybody.
I'll get to that.
And then I wrote about my hometown,
the town where somebody hit me
on the head and said go to school.
That's it Norvelt, Pennsylvania.
And then because I loved
that town I wrote about it.
And then I got older.
Oh no. And I started
reading middle school books.
Therefore I started writing them.
And this book; this is about how my
relatives taxidermed their mother.
But you know--
[ Applause ]
You think a deer head on
the wall, only family.
And then I got older.
I became like a senior
in high school.
And then I started
writing books where I got
into a little bit of trouble.
And then I predicted my
own trouble right there.
Oh my goodness.
But let's go back here.
Can you imagine that?
So all these stages of my life, and
all the books I read at each stage,
caused me to write about
every stage of my life.
Again, the reading
leads to the writing.
Choose your books wisely.
Okay. So Writing Radar.
So this is a book that
I wrote that's going
to give you some really good tips.
It's centers in on journal writing,
because that's where it all starts.
So using your journal.
Uh, that's my journal.
Now, you know all those journals
you have lying around the house?
You know how like every Christmas
or birthday somebody comes up
and goes, here's a journal."
And you write one word in it
and it goes on the shelf next
to a whole shelf of journals
that you have one word in it.
So, I would sometimes-- my
mother would say to me, hey.
Oh, this is how it would work.
I'd go to my mom, "I'm so bored,"
and she'd whip around and say,
"Why don't you get your
journal and write something."
And I'm like uh.
Wrong thing to say to mom.
So I would open the journal and
you know those blank white sheets
of paper in a journal, I would stare
at them, they would stare at me.
I would stare at them.
They would stare at me.
I don't know if this has
ever happened to you,
but my mind would go blank and
I'd feel like a complete loser.
So that's how I felt with a journal.
And then I read this book.
Have you read Harriet the Spy yet?
This is one of the
world's great books.
[ Applause ]
You only need two books
to read; Harriet the Spy
and Moby Dick and you'll be all set.
Now well George and Martha too.
I love those.
And don't forget Ms.
Nelson is missing.
That's another good one.
Oh I'm glad you do.
That's made you a better person.
Now Harriet the Spy.
So I was a library helper
when I was at school.
And I would go into the library
and this is how I would always
have a great day at school.
I'd walk into the library
and I'd say
to the librarian I'd
go, you know what?
I'm a great reader and the
librarian would go, I love you.
You come with me.
I will protect you from all of the
sociopathic children at this school.
And so I used to put the
books back on the shelf,
and help move things around.
I was always just a really
good friend to the librarian.
In the meantime, I had
this one little feeling
that I wasn't doing what I
needed to do with my journal.
Because I kept thinking
I should be writing.
I love books, I want to
see my name on a book,
but I wasn't doing anything
until I read Harriet.
And you know what Harriet did?
She walked around her
neighborhood spying
on everybody and writing it down.
I thought, I'll do the same
thing if it worked for Harriet.
So I went to the G section.
My name is Gantos.
I went to the G section of the
library and I stuck my hand
into a slot where exactly
where a book--
if I had written a book where it
would go and I stuck my hand there
and I promised myself-- I promised
myself I would write a book
and it would go right
between Galdone and George.
Boom, right there.
And then that so freaked me
out I ran out of the library.
But I didn't forget.
So here's what I did.
I took my journal;
this is my journal.
My fifth grade journal.
And I put it-- you know that
bike with the bicycle basket?
I put it in that basket and I rode
around my neighborhood
spying on everybody.
So this is my first spy map.
This map got me started.
So this is Fort Lauderdale, Florida.
See on that bottom?
See that picture with the dog?
That's my house; the Gantos family.
My mother called us the
high-supervision family
in the neighborhood.
If you played at my house you
had rules and regulations.
Nobody came to my house.
If you came to my house my
mother'd make you clean.
So we all played over at
the Pagoda family house.
My mother called them the
low-supervision family
in the neighborhood and she
forbid me to play there,
but I was there every day.
Because when you played with the
Pagodas, well you came back bruised.
It was good play.
I'll get to them.
They were a little
nutty, a little dangerous,
but they were great to write about.
And then back to my house.
See that dog in the backyard.
That's my dog Bobo.
He was asleep in the
backyard an alligator came
out of the canal and
took that dog away.
Was such a sad moment.
And there I was standing
in the backyard yelling
at Bobo, come on Bobo.
You can get away.
Bobo buddy did not get away and
I wrote about that and I wrote
and I cried in that book.
I loved that dog.
And I wrote about the love of
an animal that you always have
and how it's such a pure love.
And see that little
circle in the square?
That's called Jack's stain.
That's where I ate three
plates of spaghetti,
walked into the living room,
said to my mother I think
I'm going to be sick.
She said get to the bathroom.
I didn't. I just looked at my mother
and went bleh, threw
up right at her.
I missed her.
I hit the wall and we never could
get the stain off of the wall.
[ Laughter ]
And Florida's very humid and
on a humid stain, the smell,
that little vomity
smell would just be
like a shadow moving
around the house.
You'd wake up in the
morning sniff the air.
You'd go [sniffing].
Oh the stain's visiting
me today you know.
[ Laughter ]
Next door Mr. Vilucci built a boat,
launched it, sank in 15 minutes.
Not good at that job.
That's that dog over
there that bit me,
[inaudible] airplane
crash in our neighborhood.
Oh the Frosts and Hunts.
Grumpy old people in
the neighborhood.
Florida you have millions of them.
And you know what they were?
Retired school teachers.
[ laughter ]
That come down from Minnesota.
Talks for 50 years,
sick and tired of kids.
And you as a kid, of course
you knew that instantly
because you could nose it out.
And then you'd go dancing
across your yard.
And they would then put up
that sign that says no standing
on the yard, no walking on the yard.
Then you'd dance across it and
then you'd go send out the dog
because they always had like a
Chihuahua that would come out.
Like untie your shoe.
You'd be like oh I'm so scared.
And then the M&Ms I love them.
The Metric family.
Now they were something to
write about they had seven kids.
And they gave each one
of them an M first name.
Michael Metric, Megan Metric,
Marshall Metric, Michelle Metric
and then we'd just caught on.
We started calling them the
M&Ms; plain and peanut 2,
melt in your mouth,
not in your hand.
And then we lined them up
one day and went green M&Ms,
yellow M&M, brown M&M, orange M&M.
then we just knocked on the door.
Hello Mrs. M&M, can
orange come out and play?
[ Laughter ]
And then that's me, my
brother Pete, my sister Betsy.
This was the first bit of
evidence that I had in my journal
that I actually had
good story material.
So let's just pause for a moment.
Remember Harriet the spy?
Going around spying on things.
Draw on the map, getting
it down and then
when you see it, you
believe it, right?
When you look at a blank sheet
of paper, it gives you nothing.
You look at a map,
it gives you ideas.
So then I went to my
house and I drew my house.
So this is where I want you to start
because you don't know
your neighbors
and they might just be psychotic.
So I want you to just start
with your house and even
if they're sociopathic,
they love you.
So nonetheless, that's
the dining room table.
That's where I threw up on the wall.
That's Zippy the Roach.
My sister was taking a nap
one day we'd had an argument
and she always slept with her mouth
wide open because she has allergies.
And I had a little roach collection.
You know those cockroaches in
Florida, those really big ones.
I had this huge Lego
collection and I used
to make this giant walled city,
medieval city called Roachville.
And then I'd go outside
and I'd capture all
of these Florida roaches,
take my sister's nail polish
and write names on
the backs of them.
And then you'd take a
roach with a name on it,
put it on a Hotwheels car,
scotch tape it on there
and then you could drive them
all to Roachville, right.
You'd have roaches at a dinner
party, roaches running around,
roaches go this way, that way.
At any rate when I
saw her open mouth
after our argument I gave my jar
of roaches a shake and I pulled one
out that said Zippy on it.
I said Zippy not good for you.
What's he know, he's a roach.
[ Laughter ]
I snuck over, leaned,
aimed and let him go.
[ Laughter ]
Straight down.
Hit her on the lip bounced
up, right in the mouth.
By then I turned around and I run
back down the hallway and I dive
into my bedroom and then
I just listen deliciously.
And I hear ugh, ugh, ugh.
Phew. And then I hear
a shoe go whax,
splat and I'm like oh,
not good for Zippy.
[ Laughter ]
And then I hear down the
hallway, thump, thump, thump,
thump and it's my sister.
And she comes into my room and
she looks at me and she goes,
there's only one person
sick enough in this house
to do what just happened to me.
And I'm like that's
right, that would be me.
She goes now you have to
suffer a wicked punishment
or I'm going to tell mom.
I'm like, well, what's
the punishment?
She said, take off all
your clothes and run naked
around the outside of the house.
I said, I can't do that.
She said, I'll tell
mom she'll kill you.
I go, okay I'll take the clothes
off -- because my mom would have.
And so I took off all my clothes,
ran out the back sliding glass door.
I ran screaming all the
way around the house.
I get back to the back door.
Click. She's locked the back door.
[ Laughter ]
I run to the window.
She's locked every window.
I dash to the front door.
She beat me to the front door.
And now a very naked,
desperate boy jumping up
and down on the front porch.
I have no idea what to do next.
I look over at the
Pagoda's house next door.
I see some laundry
hanging on the line.
Things I've never seen
before in my life.
I go I don't know what that
is, but I have to wear it.
And so I run nakedly
across the Pagoda's yard
when Mrs. Pagoda catches
me [inaudible]
and yells out what are you?
Some kind of a nut.
I'm like, ah.
I turn around, come back,
still have no idea what to do.
So I dive behind those bushes
in the front of the house
and I stay hunkered down,
sitting there whimpering nakedly
until that evening my father
pulls the car in the driveway
and his naked son jumps out
of a bush in front of the car.
I thought my father was
going to run me over.
I was crying.
I said, she's so mean.
She's so wicked.
She said, who are you talking about?
I said my sister, Betsy.
He goes, well what did you do?
I said, well I dropped
a roach in her mouth.
He goes, well.
[Inaudible].
Maybe you deserved this.
He said now go in the house, you're
embarrassing me naked out here.
I said, oh I've already been
naked out here for hours.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway. See that little story.
That little story just
pops right off of the map.
I can go around that map,
everything you see drawn on there,
I've written a story about, and
it all starts with your life.
So the very first thing you
need to do as a writer--
the very first thing you need
to do is put yourself
first in your writing life.
Right from the first-person
point of view.
I said, I did, I am, I will.
You see how powerful that
I is, that first person.
I'm in charge.
That's what you want.
Now I want you to brainstorm
in your journal.
I want you to make a list to
go with your map, action words.
Brothers, sisters,
parents, pets, dumb stuff.
Don't leave dumb stuff off your list
because that's 50% of literature.
Secrets, disasters, schools,
lying, finding stuff,
public humiliation,
that's' like 49%.
And then the rest is
just 1,5 like school.
That's 1%.
And then friends maybe.
Over there on the other side, see
where it says emotional words?
We all have a great, strong
vocabulary for action.
We have a weaker vocabulary
for emotion,
so we have to make sure we get some
good, solid, emotional lead words.
Confused, proud, curious, bored,
loved, jealous, panicked, trusting,
awkward, brave, amused, powerless.
Isn't that great, huh?
Don't you just feel that
way as a kid some days?
Powerless.
And then accomplished.
That's always good.
And then that goes in your journal.
With that map.
And then you take that very
same map and I want you to go
with every action drawing you have
and then add an emotion,
a strong emotion.
So like where I dropped that
roach in my sister's mouth.
Right it's Zippy the Roach.
Pain. I suffered pain;
physical and emotional.
So not only do you have the action,
now you also have the emotion.
And when you're thinking
of literature,
you say, what is literature?
Literature, the answer to that is
all the action in the physical world
and all the emotion on the inside.
So you're always working both
sides of the human condition;
the physical world,
the interior world.
The dropping the roach,
the suffering of the pain.
So then from there, you
need to organize your story.
So I want you to just draw
a little chart like this.
It's already in the book.
So you can get it that way.
Character, setting, problem, that
goes right to eh beginning, right?
Characters, me and my sister.
Setting, the living room.
Problem, ah we've been bickering.
Situation, I drop a roach.
Action, right.
Action. Then I have the
runaround the house,
I'm trying to get some clothes.
Crisis, the door is locked.
Resolution, solve the problem.
I can't solve that problem.
I have to hide in the
bushes all date.
And then the double-ending.
Remember this.
Remember the physical
world, the emotional world?
Why would you have a double-ending?
Because you need an
ending for the physical
and an ending for the emotional.
Physical world, finally got some
clothes back on; emotional world,
had to come to the conclusion
that my sister was smarter
and tougher than me.
Now, character, setting,
problem; right to the beginning.
Action, crisis to the middle;
resolution physical
and emotional ending.
So now. You have a journal.
You've got a map.
On the map , you've got
physical; you've got emotional
and you also have a structure.
You know what you need next?
Discipline.
So here's what I'd do.
Everyday I'd wake up in
Boston, where I live.
My rule in life is live
next door to the library,
because I write all my
books in the library.
So I get up, I feed
the cats and then
after I feed the cats,
I go to the library.
I do two hours of first
draft writing,
two hours of second draft
writing, two hours of reading,
four hours of rewriting and
I go home, which is close
because I live next
door to the library.
And here's what I'm
asking you to do.
Ten minutes a day.
That's all I want.
You're young writers.
You're just starting out.
You're just getting your journal set
up like a real professional
writer's journal.
So start with ten minutes.
You draw that map, you
focus in on something.
You just write furiously
for ten minutes.
You don't know where it's
going, don't worry about it.
Just get it in there.
Next day, ten minutes.
Next day ten minutes.
It builds, builds, builds.
Two weeks, now you've captured that
really good first draft of a story.
Then you bring the structure to it.
You polish it up and then you
have something called literature.
And it's all about you.
How am I doing?
Am I done?
I'm just about done.
Okay. Boom.
So drafts.
Now I do 100 drafts.
I'm not asking you to do 100 drafts.
I just want a couple.
Point-of-view, remember
what the point of view is?
First person right.
I am, I said.
Structure.
Apply all elements of writing.
Beginning, middle, end.
We just did that with
that cockroach story.
Physical draft.
Then I want you to read
your story and make sure all
of the physical details
are in there.
Then go back and read it and make
sure all the emotional details are
in there.
Then theme.
Hey, what's that story about?
My sister's smarter than me.
Make sure you get that in there.
Dialogue. Make sure
your characters speak.
When your characters
speak they pop alive.
They become three dimensional
and you're a genius.
And then descriptions
and right words.
You want to make sure
you love the language.
Make it poetic, make it beautiful,
make it represent the
best of what you can do.
Then you review what it is.
Then you rake out all those extra
verys, ands, ifs buts and that word
like which nobody likes anyway,
but you have to keep
50% of them for similes.
But nonetheless you clean
it all up and that's
when it starts looking good.
And then you bam, you put your name
on it and that's a piece of work;
that you're proud of, you
worked hard on, hard for
and I will be reading
your good book.
Because I have talked straight
through for 25 minutes,
we do not have time for questions
but I thank all of
you for being here.
This is a great festival.
I love it.
Thank you DC.
[ Applause ]
Good luck with your writing.
>>This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.